bonsoir nous sommes le 4 mars 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction et nous parlerons tout à
l'heure de la guerre des drones qui se
poursuit hier soir plusieurs de ces
engins volants aperçu sur paris près de
la tour eiffel mais aussi le château de
versailles on parle d'une dizaine de
signalements au total durant cette nuit
des milliers de foyers privés
d'électricité en ile-de-france ce matin
les hauts-de-seine et les yvelines sont
concernés mauvaise surprise pour les
franciliens en réveil vous entendrez les
explications de erdf
l'estaca école d'ingénieurs va
accueillir à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plus de mille étudiants dès le mois de
septembre le chantier pour la
réalisation des locaux s'achève et en
plateau avec sa directrice pascal ribot
nous verrons elle est retombée à
attendre pour le territoire
c'est une véritable guerre des drones
qui s'engage une soixantaine de ces
engins ont survolé paris ou encore des
centrales nucléaires depuis le mois
d'octobre dernier cette nuit une
nouvelle étape a été franchie avec des
signalements sur paris dans le quartier
de la tour eiffel à charenton aussi dans
le val de marne aux portes de bagnolet
montreuil et vincennes et selon nos
confrères du parisien au dessus du
château de versailles la direction du
château que nous avons contactées qui
dit ne pas confirmer cette information
quant à la direction départementale de
la sécurité publique elle nous précise
officiellement qu'il n'existe aucun
élément permettant de le prouver à
l'heure actuelle le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve et qui a
annoncé cependant qu'il allait prendre
des mesures pour tenter de contrôler ces
drones qui survole des zones interdites
et vous avez vous peur de ces drôles et
de l'usaj qui pourrait en être fait
c'est notre question du jour et c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude dont
j'avoue que je n'ai pas peur non enfin
en ce moment c'est l'assurance demande
ce que c'est exactement fins et c'est
bizarre comme qui est-ce qui
commanditent savons c'est bizarre oui
c'est vrai que c'est pas rassurant
surtout que la police n'a pas l'air de
pouvoir
-enfin comment dirais-je pouvoir
intercéder facilement et qui en a de
plus en plus pour l'instant
celles qui sont densité cette question
de technologie sont pas ils sont
inoffensifs pour l'instant et mais je
comprends bien qu'il faille une
régulation assez rapide
ça peut être inquiétant effectivement
par rapport des esprits mal tordu qui
pourrait s'en servir à avec des
intentions mal intentionnés corps de mme
en prenant sur la tête
et puis bon c'est pas forcé n'a pas
forcément envie d'être observés dans son
jardin des choses comme ça après
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment on
peut pas les arrêter et que prévoit la
législation pardon sur ses vols de ces
drones nous allons écouter à présent le
porte parole de la dg a cessé la
direction générale de l'aviation civile
et ne donne quelques éléments importants
la réglementation au fait elle distingue
deux catégories d'utilisateurs
on a le grand public et les
professionnels lorsque vous êtes grand
public
on se réfère aux règles de
l'aéromodélisme et quand vous êtes un
professionnel
vous rentrez dans le cadre d'activités
dites particulière où vous avez quatre
scénarios d'activités qui sont définis
en fonction du type de drones que vous
utilisez dans les deux cas les
conditions d'insertion dans l'espace
aérien
elles sont libres en dessous de 150 m
mais à trois conditions la toute
première c'est en dehors des
agglomérations
des rassemblements de personnes et
d'animaux deuxièmement c'est en dehors
des zones proches des aéro
au port et enfin en dehors des espaces
aériens qui sont réglementés sur les
cartes aéronautique comme les espaces
aériens militaires ou les zones de
centrales nucléaires par exemple aucun
lien avec le survol des drones de cette
nuit mais soixante quinze mille foyers
se sont retrouvés privés d'électricité
très tôt ce matin en ile de france c'est
un problème technique explique la
direction d'electricité réseau
distribution de france erdf la panne a
affecté notamment une partie des
habitations de versailles mélanie poker
il était 4 heures 43 ce matin quand
environ cent mille clients de rdf de la
région parisienne ont subi une coupure
d'électricité
en cause un incident dans un poste
source située à châtillon dans les
hauts-de-seine
ouvrage qui transforme la très haute
tension géré par au transport
électricité réseaux en 220 mio en en
réseau def si la coupure a
principalement touché les hauts-de-seine
7% des foyers étaient dans les yvelines
il y avait trois communes étaient
concernées la commune de versailles à
hauteur d'un peu plus de trois ans au
plus ensuite la commune de viroflay
également pour un peu plus de 3000
clients et puis quelques clients une
vingtaine le courant a été entièrement
rétablie aux alentours de 8 heures ce
matin pour leur erdf ne peut annoncer
qu'une avarie
une enquête est en cours pour déterminer
les raisons de cette panne politique et
la droite qui affiche son unité pour les
départementales c'était le mot d'ordre
de ce meeting de l'ump mardi soir à
poissy salle comble pour les ténors de
la droite de gérard larcher le président
du sénat à pierre bédier le président du
conseil général président sortant ils
sont venus appelé à la mobilisation pour
éviter l'abstention catherine mulato
williams elle était sur place
une salle conquise une unité affichée
ump ou du modem rassembler pour ces
départementaux
nous avons réussi à faire une très belle
unité de la droite du centre jusqu'au
modem de toutes les sensibilités de la
droite qui sont réunis aujourd'hui pour
gagner des cantons qui sont jusqu'à
présent réputée ingagnable
je pense à trappes je pense à guyancourt
il ya des challenges importants j'en
citerai que trois l'emploi le transport
l'environnement et la solidarité envers
les plus démunis
et là je pense qu'il faut qu'on renforce
nos actions falloir qu'on soit mal un
inventif créatif innovant
c'est un exercice difficile
l'union être capable de trouver des
candidats communs mais ça nous
paraissait à lui dit à l'ump nécessité
parce que l'essentiel est en jeu
l'avenir des usines
la crainte pour ce scrutin l'abstention
et le choix du vote du front national
alors que l'avenir des départements de
n'est pas clairement défini leurs
compétences non plus pour les électeurs
ils sont assez perdu des compétences qui
ne sont pas encore fixées par la loi et
dans un scrutin qui manifestement du mal
à toucher les citoyens il faut leur dire
aux citoyens que c'est très important
parce que c'est leur proximité
quotidienne qu'elle soit sociale qu'elle
soit territoriale qu'elles soient les
collèges où qu'elle soit par exemple on
le sait maintenant l'aménagement des
routes
l'ump et ses partenaires ont détaillé
leur programme pour ces départemental
avec un volet social en direction des
demandeurs d'emploi la mise en place par
exemple d'une auto école sociale et
d'une halte garderie pour les parents en
recherche d'emploi il a aussi été
question d'innovation et du
développement du numérique dans les
établissements scolaires des
propositions qui devront donc convaincre
les électeurs pierre becquet de son côté
a appelé à la mobilisation générale
l'appel du 3 mars sera-t-il entendu
réponse dans les yeux et en marge de ce
rendez vous nous avons fait réagir
pierre bédier sur ses relations
particulièrement tendues à l'heure
actuelle avec le front national à
travers l'ensemble des différents
cantons des yvelines les candidats de
marine le pen ont pris pour cible le
président sortant du conseil
départemental lui-même en campagne vous
l'avez compris sur mantes
je crains que dans le département des
yvelines beaucoup de deuxième tour
une majorité de deuxième tour choix ump
fn et donc avec des risques de chutes
notre objectif c'est le grand chelem
mais la faiblesse du ps qui nous faisait
espérer le grand chelem ne peut nous
permettre de le faire que si nous
arrivons à contenir un front national
qui est démagogique et pas très
opérationnelle l'invité de ce 4 mars à
présent pascal ribot bonsoir vous êtes
la directrice de l'estaca c'est l'école
d'ingénieurs qui s'installe actuellement
à saint quentin en yvelines sur
montigny-le-bretonneux on ne peut pas
manquer le chantier qui se terminent
actuellement près de la gare ouverture
aux étudiants en septembre ils seront en
ville un peu plus même us
est-ce que tout sera prêt à temps et
bien tout sera prêt à temps
effectivement puisque le bâtiment va
nous être livrés fin mais on a tenu au
délai c'est pas souvent dans les dents
et chantilly mais ça a été le cas donc
on a parfaitement tenu les délais et du
coup on va pouvoir déménager cet été on
déménage complètement faire nous a créé
locaux temporaires effectivement je n'ai
pas apprécié et l'a aussi sur 50
on ferme notre établissement de on
termine l'année sur levallois on ferme
notre établissement de levallois on
déménage tout pendant l'été et à fin
août début septembre on sera prêt pour
accueillir nos étudiants sur mon team
donc les inscriptions qui ont lieu en ce
moment permettre aux étudiants donc de
postuler pour pouvoir s'inscrire dans
cette école tout à fait l'annoncé tombe
bien tout à fait ça se passe plutôt bien
puisque maintenant les étudiants savent
que la rentrée se fera sur saint quentin
en yvelines et donc pas sur levallois où
on leur explique les conditions dans
lesquelles on va les accueillir lors des
journées portes ouvertes rohff et
malheureusement sur levallois donc ils
peuvent pas voir les locaux et donc
qu'ils sont ils sont bien au fait et on
a vu d'ailleurs les candidatures
augmenté par rapport à l'année dernière
combien de candidature est à peu près
alors c'est assez délicat de le dire
parce qu'on est à les candidatures ne
sont pas encore terminées en fait donc
inscrire sur le site abb jusqu'à jusqu'à
fin jusqu'à fin mars le 20 mars et la
clôture en fera un point c'est alors à
ce moment-là ce moment là on va préciser
les champs d'action de cette école
l'estaca vous êtes spécialisé dans les
transports et la mobilité
peut-être préciser un petit peu quand
même tout à fait donc nous on forme des
jeunes gens qui vont travailler sur des
métiers d'ingénieurs
dans l'industrie les transports qui
roule qui volent jusque dans les étoiles
nos jeunes ingénieurs ont travaillé
plutôt sur des métiers l'innovation
beaucoup sur des sur la conception la
conception de la voiture du futur
l'avion électrique le train le train à
grande vitesse a les projets les grands
projets transports collectifs
le projet grand paris explique le choix
justement vous parlez du grand pari de
s'installer à saint quentin en iv aussi
avoir cette interaction avec les autres
entreprises tout à fait une semaine
qu'on a cherché quand un appartement où
on a fait le choix de quitter notre site
sur lequel on était installé depuis une
trentaine d'années on a cherché un
territoire sur lesquels on allait
pouvoir retrouver à la fois des
entreprises avec lesquelles on avait
l'habitude de travailler un secteur
industriel avec lequel on avait
l'habitude de travailler
et puis à d'autres aussi d'autres écoles
qui partageaient les mêmes enjeux c'est
à dire les enjeux d'innovation
technologique est donc assez
naturellement finalement ce à la fois le
grand territoire de l'opération
d'intérêt national paris saclay nous est
apparu le bon territoire et puis et puis
en particulier département des yvelines
qui est un département alors dédiée à la
voiture on l'a beaucoup dit mais aussi
on a beaucoup de nos partenaires de
l'industrie aéronautique dans cette jv
liens qui sont créé des partenariats qui
sont signés avec des pme alors on avait
surtout des partenariats avec les
grosses entreprises avec lesquelles on
avait l'habitude de travailler mais
assez vrai que notre notre souhait c'est
véritablement à partir demain on sera là
de développer les partenariats avec les
pme parce que on a une école c'est aussi
un lieu finalement ou les pme peuvent
venir trouver du la capacité à faire de
la recherche à faire du développement à
trouver des solutions à leurs problèmes
on a plus de mille étudiants une équipe
d'enseignants chercheurs
ça veut dire ça leur permettra d des
débouchés à ses étudiants aussi ce sont
des c'est une filière véritablement kiki
qui embauchent etc
c'est un secteur qui embauche le secteur
des transports est un secteur qui
embauche de façon le ton bien de le dire
vu le contexte par exemple dans
l'industrie automobile on a on a parfois
on a tenu des discours assez négatif sur
l'industrie automobile français
sur le fait que les entreprises étaient
en situation difficile mais ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il ya un fort redémarrage
en particulier dans les sous traitants
les équipementiers vont très bien et nos
étudiants là qui sont sortis l'année
dernière dans la filière automobile ont
eu aucune difficulté à trouver des
débouchés et c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'industrie en france on refera un
point avec vous sur ce sur cette
question je vais vous poser forcément au
moment de la rentrée de cette école de
l'estac est mais vous voulez
sensibiliser les jeunes femmes aux
métiers au monde de de l'ingénieur c'est
un enjeu majeur pour l'école vous dit
tout à fait alors moi en plus je suis
président de la commission diversité à
la conférence des grandes écoles donc
c'est un c'est un enjeu auquel je suis
particulièrement sensible puis
probablement tant que femme on n'est pas
beaucoup de femmes à diriger les écoles
d'ingénieurs les entreprises cherchent à
diversifier leurs équipes
les équipes de recherche des équipes de
r&d les équipes de production une équipe
diversifiée avec des différences de
culture des différences d'origine des
différences de sexe c'est une équipe qui
est plus petit plus efficace qui est
plus dynamique ya plus d'idées et donc
c'est ben finalement ça produit plus est
dans un monde qui est dominé par
l'innovation par la créativité c'est une
bonne chose
merci parce qu'avec notre passé sur ce
plateau nous ferons un point sur cette
ouverture de l'école d'ici au mois de
septembre l'estaca en septembre à saint
quentin en yvelines merci à thierry je
propose juste pour terminer quelques
images du prochain film de jamel
debbouze pourquoi j'ai pas mangé mon
père les images du film et non pas les
images sur europe 1 le film qui sortira
en salles le 8 avril c'est nous avons
les images ce serait mieux où on les
verra demain dans le journal je vous
propose en tout cas d'écouté jamel
debbouze parce que lui est revenu ce
matin sur europe1 donc sur cette
polémique autour des restos du coeur
autour de la dernière chanson des
qui met en scène des jeunes
critiquant leurs aînés célébrités
anonymes ils sont nombreux à juger
réactionnaire ce clip cette chanson ce
qui n'est pas le cas de djamel debbouze
écoutez le
c'est pas concurrents mais voilà servir
à chaud donc retourner à l'antenne pour
vous souhaiter une excellente soirée on
mettra tous les éléments dans le bon
ordre et ce sera à découvrir dans le
journal de demain très belle soirée sur
tv fier
vous